radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green now
has made the very brave declaration that
she refused to wear the coveted vaccine
I don't know what on Earth that means
either she filmed this video alongside
her new partner Brian Glenn that's the
dude who always looks sunburned and
stoned during the Trump rallies on right
side broadcasting network and interviews
people they are now together much
speculation about whether Glenn is
responsible for the breakup of Marjorie
Taylor Green's marriage don't know don't
really care but they both now are
talking about masks and vaccines
Marjorie Taylor green says she never
wore the vaccine and her boyfriend
actually seems to dodge the vaccine
question when she says you know you're
not vaccinated he seems to skip over
that and only talk about masks which is
kind of interesting take a look at this
well and I'll be upfront and honest with
you
um I'm not vaccinated I always refuse to
wear the vaccine and and I wore mask a
little bit some of the time but it got
to a certain point where I refused the
mask as well Brian you're not vaccinated
you you're not you I didn't want to wear
the mask at all and a lot of times in
the airport I was asked to put it on and
I would for a second and I would take it
off yes there you go very very proud and
Powerful Act of defiance so anyway he
just skips over whether or not he's
vaccinated but she says she won't wear
the vaccine tin foil hats she'll gladly
wear but the vaccine she's not willing
to strap onto herself so what I think is
the most important you know we
as we continue to just learn and get
more information about everything that
went on in the covet era there's
learning for everybody to do you know
the the original vaccine very effective
at preventing transmission the more
recent versions of the vaccine against
the more recent variants
almost completely ineffective at
preventing transmission still very good
at preventing illness or death and
reducing the odds that you end up uh in
the hospital okay so we're learning
about that one of the things that we're
also learning about is the hypocrisy
that knows no bounds from members of the
Republican party and people like
Marjorie Taylor green they cry about
masks and how mask requirements are
discriminatory and they're potentially
illegal they love to say etc etc but
they are completely on board
with this systematic
push for laws that discriminate against
LGBT people and folks who aren't
Christian and women telling them you
don't have any right to decide for
yourself with medical professionals what
is right for you and your family we're
going to tell you no abortion it's going
to be against the law and we might even
prosecute you or the doctor or whoever
if you try to procure an abortion the
this idea of discrimination you're
discriminating against me by saying I
have to wear a mask or to the extent
that there were vaccine requirements at
certain points in time the the
businesses are the ones now
discriminating wait a second you have
been pushing a politics for decades of
letting businesses do whatever they want
you don't even want many of these folks
don't even want protected classes of
people they always say listen a business
should be allowed to say we don't serve
black people or gay people and then
customers can choose not to patronize
that business if they don't like that
policy for decades they've been saying
don't restrict what businesses can do
all of a sudden businesses say well some
of us are going to require a vaccine or
some of us are going to require oh
that's a good that should be illegal
you're discriminating against people who
don't want to wear a mask or shouldn't
wear a mask because of carbon dioxide
conspiracies or whatever the case may be
the hypocrisy knows no bounds even on
serious issues that they claim to be at
the top of the uh policy questions that
they believe our government should be
dealing with so they are hypocrites many
of them are also Liars you know that I I
go back to the Tucker Carlson ranting
against the vaccines for so long he and
his family almost certainly vaccinated
Fox News had that policy in place where
if you weren't vaccinated they really
made your your your day-to-day pretty
tough
and he never mentioned he was being
subjected to it so they often lie they
are hypocrites but the real victims are
the people who don't really know any
better and they follow them and they
believe the things they say and they
make decisions that are disastrous for
their own families and I'm not talking
about necessarily even medical decisions
I'm talking about economic decisions
employment all sorts of decisions the
people spouting the nonsense don't
suffer but those who have Fox News and
Marjorie Taylor Green's podcast and real
America's voice as their primary news
sources those are the folks that suffer
at the end of the day